sie führen krieg im namen des islam
afghanistans taliban sind zurück 20
jahre nach ihrer entmachtung durch die
usa und ihre verbündeten drei tage
dürfte unser afghanischer kameramann sie
begleiten eine lebensgefährliche mission
in einer region die fast vollständig
unter kontrolle der taliban steht sowie
inzwischen fast die hälfte des landes
diese reise ist vielleicht vorläufig
eine der letzten gelegenheiten einen
einblick in ihren parallel statt zu
bekommen denn die taliban drohen dem
westen mit krieg sollte dieser nicht im
mai seine truppen abziehen
unsere botschaft an die nato und ihre
mitglieder ist wenn sie wollen dass ihre
kinder in frieden aufwachsen wenn sie
frieden in ihren ländern wollen dann
sollten sie unser land verlassen und die
besatzung beenden
unterwegs auf dem highway number one
mein kollege messi hat eine verabredung
mit den taliban in der provinz ghazni
eine gefährliche reise die wichtigste
verbindungsstraße von kabul in den süden
afghanistans ist ein schlachtfeld
immer wieder springen die aufständischen
autos in die luft wer hier unterwegs ist
muss fürchten angegriffen zu werden
zwei kämpfer fahren voraus nur in
begleitung der taliban und mit ihrem
einverständnis können sich journalisten
hier fortbewegen das treffen organisiert
er ist der pressesprecher der taliban in
baggers
[Musik]
die gruppe hat das zdf eingeladen
und doch
es ist beklemmend ihnen dann tatsächlich
gegenüber zu stehen
im westen gelten sie als eine der
gefährlichsten terrororganisationen der
welt normalerweise würden sie sich nicht
so auf offener straße versammeln
die afghanische regierung greift die
gebiete unter kontrolle der
aufständischen immer wieder aus der luft
an
doch die taliban wissen um die macht der
bilder eine improvisierte militär parade
von gotteskriegern so soll die welt sie
sehen und sie wollen ihre geschichte
erzählen
deshalb ist der kommandeur der taliban
des distrikts vargas persönlich gekommen
um ein interview zu geben
seit mehr als fünf jahren kontrollieren
die mütter idee den distrikt war gast
seitdem er unter kontrolle der taliban
ist bis der distrikt ein islamisches
emirat das islamische emirat hat eigene
verantwortliche für den bereich militär
einen leiter für die kommission einen
verantwortlichen für einladungen und
führungen einen richter einen
verantwortlichen für gesundheit und wir
haben auch einen es zuständig ist für
ngo s altersunterschied der kontrolle
des islamischen emirats
fünf jahre ist es her dass die taliban
die region erobert haben
was hat sich verändert eines fällt
sofort auf es gibt keine frauen
nirgendwo in den drei tagen die nester
falls sie in begleitung von
pressesprecher mansour in den dörfern
von fahrgast riehen darf begegnen ihm
allenfalls kleine mädchen
sie dürfen sich noch in der
öffentlichkeit zeigen ihre mütter nicht
wir schützen indem gegen denn die wir
kontrollieren die würde der frauen nach
islamischem recht frauen sind wie
schwestern und wir wollen ihnen alle
rechte geben die ihnen nach dem gesetz
der scharia zu stehen
sie haben auch das recht auf bildung so
lange gesichert ist dass sie den
islamischen hijab tragen mansoor stammt
selbst von hier
er kennt fast jeden auch das ist eine
strategie der taliban
sie rekrutieren ihre kämpfer aus der
bevölkerung fast immer sind die männer
in den dörfern verwurzelt auf der straße
treffen wir mal mit bilal einen 82
jährigen bauern kannst du mir helfen ein
auto zu finden bietet der mann zur er
möchte in die nächstgelegene stadt und
sucht jemanden der ihn mit nimmt man zur
verspricht zu helfen
die taliban sorgen dafür dass die leute
nicht stehlen morden und betrügen sie
verhindern die korruption
sie wenden die regeln des koran an das
ist das was sie hier tun wenn gott ihnen
die macht gibt dann werden sie den
menschen helfen dann werden sie das land
aufbauen
sie werden verhindern dass die leute
brandschatzen dass sie stehlen und
betrügen man zur hält auf der straße ein
auto an
kannst du aber mitnehmen fragte den
fahrer nur mit bilal hat eine
mitfahrgelegenheit wie die menschen in
wolgast zu den aufständischen stehen ist
schwierig herauszufinden
mansour ist immer dabei und wer würde
schon in anwesenheit eines
pressesprechers der taliban sich trauen
kritik an ihnen zu äußern
doch so viel ist sicher der regierung in
kabul haben sie hier schon immer
misstraut seit jahrhunderten leben sie
von der landwirtschaft die kargen ernten
reichen kaum zum überleben
20 jahre aufbau hilfe des westens in
milliarden höhe
hier ist davon nur wenig angekommen der
lebensstandard in den dörfern des
distrikts c zu den niedrigsten weltweit
im krankenhaus drängen sich die menschen
manche haben einen kilometer langen
fußweg hinter sich und müssen lange
warten denn es gibt nur einen einzigen
arzt in der klinik zum ersten mal sieht
unser kameramann hier frauen auch wenn
wir aus der ferne hinter einem vorhang
werden sie von der öffentlichkeit
abgeschirmt es sind mütter die ihre
kinder gebracht haben das zumindest ist
erlaubt dr yunus hat einen vater in sein
sprechzimmer gebeten sein sohn hat eine
gestohlene zunge und hohes fieber bis zu
200 menschen behandelt der arzt pro tag
auch in afghanistan verbreitet sich
cupid 19 rasant doch es fehlt an geld
für masken und es gibt kaum
desinfektionsmittel und nicht nur das
ein großes problem ist dass wir keinen
strom haben wir haben nur batterien aber
auch nur manchmal
momentan funktioniert auch unser labor
nicht denn wir haben keine elektrizität
um es zu betreiben
immerhin eine apotheke hat die klinik
medikamente die weitgehend von
internationalen hilfsorganisationen
liefert wurden die taliban haben in
ihrem distrikt bürger einen mann der
zuständig ist mit ngo s
zusammenzuarbeiten
[Musik]
man zu hat erlaubt ihnen bei den
vorbereitungen zum gebet zu begleiten er
ist 30 jahre alt und einer der wenigen
taliban die auch über sich persönlich
erzählen
später wird es noch bei ihm zu gast sein
doch ohne kamera mancher möchte seine
frau und seine vier kinder nicht zeigen
ein mann der aufgewachsen ist in einem
entlegenen dorf zentral afghanistans auf
propaganda aber versteht er sich unsere
botschaft an die nato und ihre
mitglieder ist wenn sie wollen dass ihre
kinder in frieden aufwachsen und wenn
sie frieden in ihren ländern wollen dann
sollten sie unser land verlassen und die
besatzung beenden
wir werden das versprechen das wir
gegeben haben einhalten
wir werden ihre länder nicht von unserem
land aus angreifen
das islamische system ist unser recht es
ist das was wir wollen wenn sie bleiben
und sagen wir werden nicht gehen werden
wir unsere operationen wieder aufnehmen
in afghanistan ist jeder junge mensch
ein mudschaheddin und sie sind für opfer
bereit
deswegen sollten sie die hände von isla
die weiße flagge der taliban mit dem
ersten satz des islamischen
glaubensbekenntnis es weht über den
dörfern die sie erobert haben
es werden immer mehr eine
kommandozentrale gibt es nicht die
taliban sind flüchtig immer auf ihren
mopeds unterwegs
indem sie sich nie lange an einem ort
aufhalten vermeiden sie aufgespürt zu
werden
doch ihre kämpfer wachen über alles im
distrikt vargas selbst vor dem eingang
zur provinz schule steht ein taliban
der unterricht findet den schichten
statt früh morgens von 7 bis 11 uhr die
mädchen danach die jungen das mädchen
schulen besuchen erlauben die taliban
inzwischen doch streng getrennt von den
jungen
es gibt nur ein unterrichtsfach den
koran der lehrer ist ein muss wie viele
onkel hatte der prophet
47 rufen sie durcheinander es scheint so
wirklich wissen sie es wohl nicht
[Musik]
die schule ist ein heruntergekommenes
gebäude und der mullah der einzige
lehrer von der tafel ablesen sollen die
jungen lernen darauf liegt der wert denn
so schaffen sie es auch den koran zu
lesen
viel mehr an bildung nehmen die kinder
nicht mit
eine generation die bereits jetzt für
die regierung in kabul verloren scheint
erzogen im geiste der taliban eindrücke
die an das regime erinnern dass die
amerikaner und ihre verbündeten vor 20
jahren entmachteten und beseitigen
wollten
trotz internationaler militärhilfe in
milliardenhöhe an die regierung in kabul
kontrollieren die selbst ernannten
gotteskrieger heute fast die hälfte des
landes sie treiben steuern ein und
teilen land zu auch damit finanzieren
sie ihren krieg
zum mittagessen versammeln sich die
männer im haus eines wohlhabenden bauern
der alte mann sehr wir brot und reis und
schorba ein traditionelles gericht der
region gekochtes gemüse mit fleisch die
taliban zählen auf die gastfreundschaft
der bauern dass die bevölkerung sie
unterstützt ist für sie
selbstverständlich denn sie sehen sich
als krieger im namen des islam auch das
gebet verrichten sie anschließend im
haus fünf mal am tag versammeln sie sich
so eine heilige pflicht die sie nie
versäumen
doch diesmal wird die andacht gestört
per walkie talkie meldet sich ein
anderer kommandant er möchte wissen wo
man zur und die anderen stecken und ob
alles okay ist
bevor sie wieder aufbrechen gibt es noch
t die atmosphäre ist entspannt sie
scherzen sogar die meisten sind
familienväter und kehren abends in ihre
häuser zurück über persönliches möchten
sie nicht reden nicht einmal beim tee
warum wurden sie zu kämpfen
der grund warum ich mich den taliban
angeschlossen habe ist das ungläubige
unser land besetzt haben
deswegen müssen wir den heiligen krieg
führen der dschihad ist so wichtig wie
beten die ungläubigen sind brutal
vorgegangen sie haben eine
marionettenregierung in kabul
installiert und die taliban ins
gefängnis geworfen
doch jetzt das möchte man zu zeigen sind
sie zurück dass die taliban den gasen in
der lage sind funktionierende strukturen
aufzubauen zeigt ein besuch im gericht
der provinz jeder kann hier für
umgerechnet 8 cent sein anliegen
vorbringen und erhält ein dokument mit
einem termin zwei zerstrittene familien
sind an diesem morgen gekommen es geht
wie so oft in den entlegenen dörfern
afghanistans um landbesitz die ältesten
tragen ihr anliegen vor die eine familie
hat auf dem feld der anderen
versehentlich eine bewässerung angelegt
nun müssen sie sich einigen
richter verkehr ola fragt genau nach er
ist kein jurist sondern ein koran
gelehrter seine urteile basieren auf den
geboten der scharia
der grund warum die menschen nicht zu
der regierung gehen ist dass es dort
keine scharia gibt jemand von einem
nachbardorf wollte letztens ein problem
lösen da haben die leute von der
regierung 25.000 afghani als bestechung
haben wollen sie haben gesagt gib uns
das geld und wir lösen das problem
wir machen so etwas nicht wir haben ein
papier
dafür nehmen wir 50 afghani das sind 18
bei uns gibt es keine korruption und
auch keinen freundschaftsdienst das sind
nicht unsere regeln auch die beiden
männer die wir nicht später kommen
wollen ein urteilt er habe dem nachbarn
land verkauft und dieser habe nicht
alles bezahlt was er im schilde erzählt
der bauer
doch der andere möchte nicht zahlen da
das land nicht bewirken könne und nun
pleite sein
ich habe kein geld mehr an ihn zu
bezahlen unser geschäft ist erledigt
aber ich will nicht in zukunft in streit
mit ihm sein
der richter vertagte die verhandlung die
beiden verfeindeten bauern müssen zeugen
bringen
sie erhalten beide ein offizielles
papier mit stempeln der taliban
ein parallel statt in dem die gesetze
der regierung in kabul keine gültigkeit
haben drei tage in der region ghazni es
ist vielleicht die vorläufig letzte
gelegenheit für einen deutschen
fernsehsender einen kleinen einblick in
das regime der taliban zu bekommen
die kämpfe haben der welt ein ultimatum
gestellt sollten die internationalen
truppen nicht im mai aus afghanistan
abziehen drohen sie mit krieg auch gegen
deutsche soldaten